we aren't good right
shut up and I master Mirotic yonder
dealership yeah buddy
after hun nebula shhh all right we're in
HD a mode okay
doing something
perfectly straight highway Sunday HTA we
think it's our nectar purse on Twitter
first you to live
[Music]
we got a few discard we have 1440 nice
so I think we got to go back soon we
don't know put too many miles on this
car pretty good though it's pretty good
let's see if we get like anything at all
that's hard
which bank to be robbed yeah that's a
good question they said you'd go 163
yeah why your phone well will it make a
turn
pretty good
long did it do it yeah all right now
let's let's tapes trying to have it do
some a little art let's go
Oh God
what model Sonata Limited 2020 Oh God is
so terrifying
it does not make turns doing something
yeah that Lexus is like screw you we get
it what it's beeping about now
oh it's detecting that our line is a
lane wait this is actually really
concerning its steering right now is it
yeah how I disengage
the mode confusion on this is
unbelievable that just take the next
exit what is that sound we don't know
what was that sound because it thought
that the crack in the pavement was a
lame-o service lane departure warning
Thank You Congrats in the profitable
quarter yes thank you thank you
wait it's on next exit
[Music]
because cars kid
this later equality can I make a turn
how does driver hit monitoring handle
masks farewell
[Music]
okay
let's beat down to 31 we want to go
right or left let go left or right
[Music]
left and it does not continue you
wouldn't have seen that car you think
[Music]
but look at this cool thing you guys Oh
with the blinkers they have the okay
look at that they have the camera yeah
does this one I've stop and go
it definitely not stopping gosh this is
Sean guys I think it's the same one
that's on the palisade so it is their
highest end it has this always on seems
like a very it seems like a adaptive
cruise has anything to do with that
well just defer for our enjoyment let's
see if it off
[Music]
hey it gets a higher trim you get a
smaller engine and it's actually slower
I think he gives us more gas higher trim
slower
I love slower engine you said he has
like a 1.6 liter turbo engine look at
that space back there for Willem so much
room so much room in this car crazy oh
wow
[Music]
delayed reaction what's assisting
one sixty day you want yeah you want to
go straight straight hey don't really
yes
you want to take the exit valve little
on Avenue oh yeah
[Music]
it's good at straight lines though don't
ask it for like torque or anything like
this it probably will be okay
[Music]
I know it's nabbing me
wait why does it nag you because you
haven't touched the wheel and well
[Music]
that's pretty good yeah yeah I'd say so
like this straight line I'd say is
pretty close to open pilot to I mean
everybody can do this train line um I
haven't seen ass doing nothing
yeah like they're just - just let me
drift over that line
I'm still not sure and accurate but it
won't do well
[Music]
okay okay
West West Aries
yeah so if you're coming at all in an
angle to the lines it doesn't seem to do
anything it seems to be very like they
seem to have a very sort of it's
interesting I mean this was one of the
things discussed in the in the safety
discussions on costume forks about
whether cars can steer without being
engaged and they seem to take the
philosophy that you can but their
steering in coats are incredibly weak
so we cut it doesn't seem like like like
we'll do anything here it won't yeah the
steering wheel needs to be green it's
flashing so now it's off so it's green
like locks on I say it was just green
man okay that's interesting
oh well like it's good mom yeah can they
gets good marks yeah well so yeah we
learned yesterday that there's a some
entrepreneurial law South Korean I'm not
gonna say anything about I don't know if
they're care an adult or a man or a
woman who's been testing out I think I
took nothing literally took nothing
[Music]
who's been who's been doing free on
installation services around South Korea
got a fork HS you mm mm yeah Wow
got a fork on why isn't George wearing a
comma hoodie but food comedies like that
everyone would wear them goodbye this
car guys for what it's worth
Eric moraga says South Korea has been
buying a ton of pandas from me oh
they're buying panda that's what they do
it yeah that makes sense yeah yeah yeah
don't buy a white panda you're gonna be
very disappointed when open 5:08 comes
out about zero away it's gonna require
the GPS GPS Aston Martin stop there yeah
oh my guess it has smart park so it's
not like Park Assist I haven't seen it
put any big big torque on the steering
but here's another reason we're buying
this car
Yandex is now using them in Russia as
their base platform further
so this will be commas based platform
for our let's just say full self-driving
before is a stupid term
just just do it Yandex does you're sorry
so I'm locked on right now does this
mean I guess I don't even need the
cruise control to use this
these are something right there right
this Subaru oh yeah yeah on the other
side yeah that's terrible
all right this is let's see if it does
this yeah this intersection
alright lost it in the intersection good
point Oh everybody's the green thing ok
ok
at least the green thing is helpful for
you as the driver you know I kind of
missed like a beep or something you know
it's the same system where has to log on
but then it beeps when it locks up so
you know it's gonna work hmm
that oh yeah oh well it separates the
steering from there longer know
it is nice we shall show the broken
Trump yeah it has a broken trim see this
is a new card some serious production
problems like things falling off why
wait let's try some our park yeah so I
turn it on sorry you guys I'm like
shaking this okay it's on I press this
button use forward or backward button on
smart key after leaving vehicle so we
have to leave okay I'm not staying in
are you kidding me
what if it crashes I'll stay in this is
a little wearing this car might be
moving oh yeah yeah yeah yeah and George
is using this with the remote well there
you go
it makes sense yeah better die at some
point you guys it's not bad not really
try it's also aggressive with the brakes
at all not really not from what I saw
you can say it's pretty straight Oh Oh
interesting the sales department is open
because we learned that and they are a
essential business sales department is
an essential business you guys that was
pretty fun to be in the air look at that
though fun very nice by scobie's